I'm speaking to mr.
e h a Peach who was
a public works engineer on
the harbour bridge with dr.
Bradfield you remember those times
do you speech. Yes. We're taking
a back in the first instance where were you
born and when i was born in this is all
one night in hundred to sort all of these
and. And when did you come out here. You
came out here not in certina. With your
parents with your parents. Oh yes yes but
our family came our virtually the same time.
You member coming out. So yes we came
out on
a ceramic i'll have my voice and when we
do we use school school age at those days
. Yes which is also the primary
school nationally. Then.
We go to them. How to canterbury canterbury
you know after canterbury our went to
manly public school and from there i went
to cleveland strange. Public school so
high school. And what then.
I just started work. Where
was your first job then
with brothers in 1918 as
a cadet. And i continued my studies for
a number of years i would say until
mid 1920s principally in engineering
and what job did you get after the draft
and job. Well my first job with the
government was was the metropolitan
right i can suction when dr.
Brand her loosely. The chief
engineer. And i was with them for.
Until about nineteen twenty two twenty
three. I think it was and three or four of
us were picked. To formally
a national group that comprise
ultimately these they have
a british branch. Do you ever first getting
the job with the public works do you.
Oh yes yes. So my first job with
a public works was in nineteen twenty
twenty one and middle lush who
eventually one of the supervising engineers
out on the harm of range was employed
at the same time. Both we were both in the
metro ride construction. Did he started
the railways to yes. We you interviewed
first by dr bradfield or who
took you on so to speak. I was taken on
by the metropolitan right away. Construction.
I was interviewed by some committee
and that's where my first appointment.
When did you first meet redfield or
shortly after i joined i magine they joined
the rats borrower construction. Jeremy
the office in those days where it was. It
was in the public works department or my
third floor. And they were all
draftsmen there weren't many
engineers as such in those days because.
Engineering work on the metropolitan right
construction had barely been started. I
think what i can recall you member any of
the political hoo ha and getting the reg
going again getting there getting the
railways going again. The metropolitan
railway construction had been in abeyance.
Yes i know there was some trouble about
it was some potent political levering at
the time but i was really too young
to worry much about it and there's
a. Can i take you back to the time
when you were actually working in the
drawing office. At the metropolitan railway
construction branch you meant what your
job was and what you did well at that
time it was principally railway line the
calculations dealing with right away. Local
city railway locations. The method of
mobile occasion work it had
been developed work done on
a grid system and you had to relate. The
whole of the railway line the center line
to one fixed point which on this
occasion was there was the time ball on
the observatory that was that was the
heart and no more no more and then
and from that point every position on the
since almost thirty railway could be
determined by magically so you had no
problems and in doing just exactly where any
part of the railway came in relation to
the buildings or the offsets. It was
because of this. I think principally that
i was transferred to the harbour bridge
design people to do the same thing
on the harbour bridge and has it has
a result of that all awry well okay some
work on both approaches to the bridge was
worked out this time. As time went on. Do
you remember the surveyor did you have
anything to do with him. Mr amphlett yes
i've got an old tape of it. Up on my shit
. Once it was discarded whole thing collapse
later on. Yes i knew very well i guess
the right. Factor is to be one of his
party. Yes. Do you where do you do you
remember where his name sort of slippery
came from. Now i don't doubt it.
There are some people do call it slippery
and flip over at my he may have got that
from his early in his earlier. Surveying
work. I doubt he was now i don't remember
any he was
a pretty decent sort of grey head lice
line fairly. And my principal job was to
help
a measure of the baselines for the harbor
bridge. This was done in the quarry scene
down along the eastern side street
somewhere between much library and the
government house. I saw one baseline was
in the government has garden and there's
the governor peering through the theodolite.
Well i don't know what he did in those
days. His name was the share the
chair in those days and i tried.
But did you go out with with amphlett or
mr amphlett or did you just work for him
in the office. I don't know how i feel i
work with him. I'm trying to time you
transfer different job you're doing all in
might get some assistance. And when you
went over to the bridge. Do you remember
was it different. The work of the work you
were doing from the city really not it's
not significantly not an issue then right
. It was
a name an invention even but i know it
especially this harp member when particularly
. The original design for the appraised
sydney harbour bridge. It was two tracks
. On one side and now. It was four tracks
together two went round the observatory.
And along parallel to kent street and the
other two went almost directly down onto
when you station that of course was later
on. It was all because later on they had
a big bold plans looked as they
were bar constructed and small as
a great began. And there were two great big
boulders in the tracks so g eventually
can do is when you got enter to win sation
it's all now cause. Do you remember when
he scrapped all the plans for the railway
at that particular time i understand that
in order to do that he had to change to
be the maximum gradient of the railway
and also. Motors electric motors and all
the sort of thing came into yes yes to the
matter fact that what about quite
a big change because the national
requirement by the railway department is
a maximum rate of one in thirty and because
of that it was impossible to get off
the bridge down to when you station the lay
of the level required and. This caused
a great in this is one reason only. Why
they put the ball is to get the additional
travelling distance so i can decrease
again. But right my department and i don't
know who or why or how something issued
and edicts of their maximum guide will be
one in thirty which completely altered
the design of both the approach and
approaches on both sides. I heard it was
bradfield that did it but i don't know.
Well it could well have went because over.
I wouldn't have noticed i wouldn't have
known really and those
a but i really told us from now on it
was one and one of thirty. I believe
there was
a bit of an internal battle which i've
been trying to find out about between
a deejay faust who had
previously worked for dr.
Bradfield in the email sea
reconstruction branch and bradfield
himself who. He never became
a rally commission actually wasn't his
thing but but forced to became a rower for
a mission. And i believe it was a bit of
a battle between the two of them. You
never heard anything about it you know i
wasn't aware of it. It was the argument
was over the rolling stock over the motor
sissy was there i consider trains used to
get stuck on the way on the uphill there
. Now i want to wear that hat. You're
telling me i think. I do you know your room
as
a slam try to get some substance. Now i
don't really know you know well back to the
foster's name i remember him as
a commissioner or in the way of any. Any
friction between he and rang for him.
Do you how did you get on with dr if you.
I got on very well and is nothing but he
was a delightful person who really took
a real human interest and staff and quite
easy to get on and he he required.
One thing he did you call them fleet likely
more to the to the job and to the and.
And to the touch of rational himself any
editor gresham's away from that then
you've had a cell somewhere else.
Like what. Oh well i had it is
a bit like new you had and i kneel when
he was chief commissioner finished out in
the midwest in the midwest
always to vision.
In many ways it. It was often claimed that
redfield sort of centralized everything
through himself he took the credit for
everything he did you ever did he ever give
you credit for you or your work
or. Yes he did very much so as
a matter of fact part. Later on when
the bridge was well established.
But in order to retain the enthusiasm
forward. He was giving lectures here there
and everywhere and he is i use them right.
So i had lectures for him and. Bill.
Who was also a friend of mine.
He was my boss as well. He was
a supervising engineer would.
Wound and get things straight
arranged election wasn't and want to know
more than one occasion suggested perhaps
and. I should much like ask my
mother i was not around then
and from my and one i stay in on the prep
because he knew my mother was in the in
the audience he specifically my in the
direct you know reference to me and the
plain guard of the
preparation and the really
a lot of the the the letter brit lecture
itself but also some of the little
stations which i felt was
a very clearly. Oh he was very he was
very much like he looked after my mother
later on there was. Oh we hadn't opened
a bridge at that stage but there were one
or two little ceremonies which used to
rise for instance. Saturday afternoon the
first time over the bridge. It always
sort of is. My mother's ought to
go on. Well that was very good
. It was
a personal touch as i understand. When you
were. Well what was your job actually on
the. The design of the bitch. Surely it
was right or railway construction but
i was a bit mathematically
in sign and ice to do
a lot of math on them and. I. Had
a number of jobs today. Generally we
design work the bits here and bits their
design the the. The tiny holes on the
south side. Over a matter fact i think
the national idea of a bridge on
a bridge
a ride. I'll cut as was originally
suggested by me as far as i can recall how
do you explain that the bridge on
a bridge over the algo had well you see.
In the redesign of the southern approach
it was essential to have the roadway here
above the railway by the time it got down
to down to the song to the sun in the
contact. That's very close to i go and
cut. Now when you reached cut south.
You'd have the railway level below
the road level. So you know to carry the
two over. Not as they would. Couldn't you
couldn't keep one level you had to do
something on the road i stuck another bridge
up on the i'm allowed bridge put the right
way out there and left the right way
down low. I didn't realise
so when you look up
a cut above you. There are always running
over that. I yes there i will. Well yes
yes it will and those days
before later on. It was changed
a bit the tramways are on the west's
only sign no worse they start
a site and the railway was only
a western side and i never thought of that
when you come to use it. It's toll gate
so i was
a number of steps there and leading up
from there from the air and ground level
that i go down as i go straight and
sell all watch together. And eventually
you know how there were levels footpath
levels on both the east and the western
side and the harbor bridge right on the
western side also hand access to endorse
the observatory park. And do you have
anything to do with the design of the
approaches on the northern side. I did the
whole layout there virtually both the
railway stations how the railways and
then slowly work satiated of the roadway.
You have anything to do
with mr. Ledger and mr.
Boyd. Yes not so much
slimmer sledger but mr.
Boyd oh yes he was in charge of the drawing
office when i was only there the best
one right. I can sanction the ledger was
a it was earlier he was designing engineer
and fausto when forced it was his
principal designing engineer for the
railways for bradfield. So that'll be before
your time. But boyd. So i can remember
honestly he was a slight man with
a gray hair i mean obviously. And
i can recall he was basically
a surveyor as well as any i could have
sons went on to surveying and they had
a surveying business in town. I don't know.
And on the north side. What were the
problems there. Not
very many really it was
a fairly straightforward job. You know the
principal difficulty arose there was the
difference. In length of the bridge
by survey the length of the bridge by
construction and they didn't mean. No they
british from memory i think bridge was
a bit longer than the survey was a result
you had to get rid of about or remember
a five or six inches which was
a very accurately term and simply because
if you built them where where the matter
fact there was a. There was a bit of
a problem there because they had work
to an earlier survey which are nearly
a distance across the harbour
bridge and started to build
a museum station some of all city
station and then when hanford. And
done
a very accurate survey with instruments
brought in low especially in some was brought
in from the jail from
overseas and. He measured
the same just same distance between what
is known as being in which is benchmark
north and bed. And p.s.
Which is benchmark south. And there was
a cybersex each is different and levels
i straightaway the bridge work had been
started on the harbour bridge. Work it
been started on one or certainly preached
construction and in the ultimate they would
went. So. That i how much by how much
five or six inches. That was i just
forget it was both edges out more
in the north south direction and
it was east and west and i had
the difficult job on
a difficult deliberately of getting rid of
five inches of real estate which we know
also there in south sydney. It's your
time. It was done. How did you do it
. Oh calculations. Oh i where does the
federal count there's got to know you can
fit all. I mean you can you can links
a straight track you can trust came around
circular tracks it was quite so easy. We
wish you can't make one circle fit on
a low and accurately and these
have been thought of yes it was
a really probably you to show me it
what they want to know. They do know
. It would too short too long. I don't
know where that is now but we stretched it
one way or the other. How did the error and
did anybody ever find out how the error
originated or you never know. Noticed time
by two different surveyors and they gave
two different answers. The other there was
there was no i. There was no doubt about
that got
a goodly and something out of me not about
it. Do you remember going out into the
field at all and doing your own
surveying yes i know i am one time
dr. Bradfield was very interested in
the development of the building of
a row over tween the harbor
bridge and the manly ring
a district. And i had the job of doing
the the initial location of the
region and there was no he just it was
a dope precise way but there was i gave
a good general location which was
good enough. And as i was to
find out just where the nature of the
railway were where the station for me and.
I went out to do the survey. I didn't
do a detailed surveyors job. I did
a general so i principally i'm levelling.
The make sure the level from from lost
and me. Round three right up right
up the coast here and sorrows. Or
i think there's something like that. I've
seen those surveys i didn't see your name
on them now. No no i did in the track work.
Do you remember who you working under
at that time polite
polite. Is
a couple of other service names as well.
During that i was i believe as far as i
can see from the from the survey material
which i discovered in the. In the railway
archives that we need station there that
there was about three surveys done and
there are about three to separate routes
were proposed then does this was done very
much as
a deep metal no interest at all from the
royal wave. Well there was no evident
interest in the right way to know when
they were wondering my c they've got the
ones i've saw i saw of three separate
lights and their grave got an m.o.
See no metropolitan railway construction
but no. Yes that'll be right. Do you
remember the office up there and and
working up there and how how the
layout was between the people working on
the metropole and now we construction
branch and the people working on the harbour
bridge branch the different drawing
officers know they were there with the
different groups within the same office. I
was much more i can sanction the years.
Gemma i think about all the engineers that
were working on the bridge getting fired
from the railways round about 1928. They
all got fired by the railways. Because
the railways they were working on the
harbour bridge under bradfield and they
were salaries were paid for and they were
still working within the metropolitan really
construction of the 1920s and you were
in 1928. There were all terminated from
the railways and it's very snotty comment
appears on the record cards
which says. To be treated as
a service is dispensed with.
That's right. I was on. I went
a main road that. Oh yes very very unhappy
about that you member the politics of it
. No i don't i know how
it came to this. I don't.
Dr.
Van fleet was always very loyal to
his staff. And this this switch
the railways to the works
to underline his mind of
mind. I've seen was engineered.
It was engineered between dr.
Brand for you know i knew who
the role of the department
might raise commissioner. It was down on
you scratch my back and ask rice yours
and the deal was settled. I
believe my doctor by and feel
sure. Knew or. That he could eventually
take over my harbor bridge and its might
change if he would retain the main
railway staff which was
done. It was there was
a lot of trouble later on with runaway
staff going to main right. And they didn't
get a very good sort of
a reception. I was one of the victims i
think. That's how that was brought about i
didn't know anybody knew about it. I
thought it was the other way around as
a matter of fact i had completely misread
it in that case. What what i had thought
was the case was that this well there was
a infighting battle between fraser and
bradfield wish there was over well in the
first but there's
a long standing one fraser of course was
was railway commissioner supreme he was
the he was the first so to speak. Do you
ever meet resit oh yes i meant friday
afternoon after i left on my own right and
i was like. Oh i didn't have much to do
with him here i mean you know i was on a
comedian and. He was there and he had
a boy but frazier was
a it was his son my demand that wouldn't
be that was his son who was on that
committee that's right yes. Well it was
james fraser he was the old the old man who
was always battling redfield and
he were always battling they had
a certain respect for each other but they
were always battling when the harbour
bridge was designs were first
brought out and the tender was.
Bradfield had proposed to accept the tender
doorman long for an arch bridge with
pylons and. James fraser
recommended without pylons.
And then so it went on and then the
location also of the circular quay railway
james fraser do everything that i did the
plans for. I didn't initially planned for
the railway. The secular key railway station.
I don't know where they got it would
i can well remember even now the outline
of these things which was for me there
with all its light now. I expect but. Do
you remember who did the drawings for the
architectural drawings coulter do you
remember him. Yes. Carla what was he like
he's a very nice very he
was. He was narcotics he was
a mean jinnie. He'd he'd ask for things.
Engineering virtually impossible. And
then cleared them in these pictures and
expect wonder why they didn't look like the
same as these pictures when they were
eventually built what we nationally was he
was he as i wouldn't i would imagine he'd
been. Did it. What sort of accent did he
have. I don't recall he had an accent in
a neutral do i have an accent. Not
really because i'm feeling i've got
a family when i was a hero here is not
a neutral accent so he could have been
english or australian. How would think so
yes. Do you know where he where he
went to return. Yes he would the
government. Government i connect. Well he
was an architect with them all the way
through and they used to his drawings
used to be done on that show they sent
a voucher down here to the drawings that
may be but i'm not sure i don't know what
happened after i left the harbor bridge.
But so you your engineering drawings
hardly corresponded to what
his architectural drawings.
I see issue here. Anything.
Like you know you know times
when you've just got to do something. There's
no alternative but it didn't matter.
He put a row of cottages between. Between
a row royal i was about ten feet high and.
You couldn't do anything with it but. Do
you remember him doing is drawing over
for her descriptions of him doing these
drawings which are very very fine i've
been trying to remember him doing when
he worked fast they were done. I don't
ever remember where he worked or gordon's
doing or he worked on the architects. But
gordon stuckey says that he remembered
him doing
a drawing on one occasion with dr
bradfield was talking and this. This was
a sort of general drawing for the town
hall stations entrances and. Bradfield was
just talking and culture was drawing and
very very quickly what was done was
required. I've seen that drawing and i
guess one of the most superb drawings i've
ever seen of st.
Andrew's cathedral. Yes. Can i don't know
i have to say i know i saw plenty of his
sketches. I see him
a lot of ways and. But. He used
to come up to your office to.
Oh here probably be in the office whether
he'd come up and i have no idea where he
worked was in the shed over the road down
below the government architects. That's
right yes. Going over there some time.
Well do you remember the shed. Oh yes
. Yes. You know the single story place. I
remember right. Well that's the stuff we
have
a that's where they do these exploration.
Now the early sites the site
of the early government house yes yes yes
that's right. Some digging up there now.
Some like ya'll adjusting something oh
yes they do excavating it right at this
moment. Do you remember then.
Working on the railway the
ski railway do you remember the political
business over the over the siting of the
key railway remember when there was
a battle on over. Yes yes i
remember the result. It was
a prong of fear too but these sketches
that i used to do would try and illustrate
what it would look like if such and such
a stunt and. That's all there was of
the very actually engineering why some
portable location. It wasn't terribly
important who was at it. I don't think it was
changed very much. We were just now
you know with the proposal there was
a number of proposals where the location of
the station was a big battle between mr.
Knock knock. And kirby's who wanted it round
the corner by him and james fraser who
supported him and the rest of the people
who want bradfield who want to do in the
middle. Why can't remember that when
you know i wasn't there i was i wasn't
likely to be mixed up with that sort of
thing. Only i had pretty used to that now.
I mean why not go easily a quite well it's
a less now the workers building. It's still
there is the ironworkers building. Yes
. Not i don't know. But come back
to the bridge. What work did you
actually do. Did you do any actual work
on the harbour bridge itself on the
contract work. No physical work but on
the design where i didn't know any. Good
you see that much of the design was done
with don't want long and god had the job
of doing the departmental checks
on me but no i don't know i
didn't do very much. I used to do
a lot of running about for one reason
or i wasn't an associate of the actual
construction. Can you rember what
running around you did for dr.
Redfield. But i can't.
I. Not really know my for except i
used to do it a survey work with
a bloke called roger butler. Yes he just
died last year of the year before i hand
his his just this spotlight was
talked about security for years.
But what do you do we do
with the right about them.
Right. You had to do survey work and
the call. I mean to go help me with
a chain do
a survey work with him and when you.
So watch survey was he doing. He was
he was doing the survey work for the for
the bridge itself checking with auburn
lungs. Well yes it was the
initial investigations i.